the Boogaloo boys have uh uh been
praised for for they're not they're not
directly anti for BLM no they're not but
if you are Marching with antifa and BLM
There's no distinction sorry these
people have firebombed buildings they
have killed people uh Michael reinel in
Portland with a BLM communist tattoo on
his neck shot Aaron Danielson twice in
the chest and then you're like you know
what I'm gonna march with these people
it's like well with a with a rifle and
you pointed at someone and people are
pointing on the chat there's a video of
him holding the weapon at high ready
he's got the gun that's what I'm talking
ready to go if a guy approaches you high
ready with a rifle at high ready man in
the middle of a a riot and you're stuck
and you can't move you've got to assume
the worst what choice I'm not trying to
incite stuff but like what what are you
supposed to do in that situation you
have to protect yourself yeah you can
either just put your hands down and
stick your chest out right out of the
tip of his gun maybe but like what's the
other choice here